president biden sort of set off the left
after rejecting calls to defund the
police over the weekend and promising
more resources for law enforcement
during historic surge in violent crime
2020 was the deadliest year
for law enforcement on record
and today
we're here to remember nearly 500
of your brothers and sisters they're
going to be more resources not fewer
resources help you do your job
that's why i propose we invest in we
invest again in community policing we
know works
the one thing that protects cops is
another cop
so greg that's a convenient narrative
now would have been better off last
summer when this whole crime surge
started
i guess this was occurring during
national police week right which is i
think cnn calls it the national
appreciation of white supremacy yeah so
i don't know if they covered it uh yeah
thank you for joining us in the real
world but where were you when the cities
were burnings cops were getting attacked
uh he couldn't take a stand because that
stand aligned himself with trump so he
let politics replace his spine and he
retreated to his basement as this
country burned billions and billions of
dollars worth of damages people dying
cops committing suicide and the only
reason why he's talking about it now is
because it's a political weapon to use
against the republicans by tying it to
january 6th
but it falls apart because his
inconsistencies expose that truth he
didn't give a damn about cops
he didn't give a single damn about cops
before january 6th now he does so screw
him i don't i i
i know that i should be bet i should be
more diplomatic and say i'm glad he
finally came around but i'm so cynical
at this point because he didn't do jack
for so long it actually infuriates me
and it's hard to infuriate me dana i
know you have a very very calm i'm
jovial most of the time i know you're
also a wonderful he's mad yeah i'm very
mad right now dane i'm very mad but dana
on that the cynical point you know
democrats were getting destroyed when it
came to the defund the police issue in
the south carolina senate race in the
virginia house races so is this a way to
kind of change the narrative ahead of
2022. i think in a way
one of the reasons is cynical and it's
frustrating is that you actually believe
that that is the real joe biden speaking
if you go back to 1994 and the thing the
the crime bill then things he has said
in the past is support for police and
then there was this political moment and
he did um not stand up when you needed
him to so then you think well will the
real joe biden please stand up if crime
is in the headlines president biden
knows that he's losing because that is
something that everybody will pay
attention to and the first story that
will always get covered is going to be
crime and so
like inspector gadget the left's message
is self-destructing and it's not just on
this issue i would say it's also
happening on immigration what happened
this weekend the brighton administration
says they're going to return to the
return and
remain in mexico policy that president
trump had and the left-wing people that
were on the zoom call with the biden
administration walked out of the meeting
they found out this week that it's
likely that the climate proposals and
the big infrastructure bill are going to
be pulled out so they're dejected over
that they're depressed because the biden
administration will not be able to
deliver on this voting rights bill that
they want to pass so all of this is
leading the president to maybe rethink
some things you know jesse the speech
from uh president obama over the weekend
had a lot of nice things that he said uh
but personnel is policy and if you look
at doj and like kristin clark or anita
gupta both people who call to defund the
police who believe the whole system is
racist those are the people running the
show when it comes to investigations and
policies on a federal level for police
departments across the country and they
haven't really offered much in terms of
backing the police in the way that the
president called for that's why people
think he's a puppet because he doesn't
even pick his own people to staff some
of these departments you guys are both
right he was anti-crime in the 90s and
he attacked back during the primary when
he was getting hammered then after floyd
he said oh we have systemic racism in
our police departments but we should
redirect funding from the police and
then he hid in silence in his basement
and then when he saw the democrats
almost lose the house in november
because of this he tried to tack back
again so that's why no one trusts him
he's too wishy-washy and he hasn't even
pushed his anti-crime and police reform
bills through congress he controls both
houses and they're both doa police
departments need strong leadership vocal
support from the commander-in-chief
because they're putting their lives on
the line they're making split second
calls car pursuits foot pursuits dealing
with some of the most horrific people as
greg says people on their worst days in
america and they're just going to retire
stick around and stay in their squad
cards not do proactive policing if
they're not getting vocal support from
the white house and that's what we're
seeing right now he has to convince his
party to be
less
anti-police if he's going to stand a
shot for people to believe him yeah well
guys that put their lives on the line
every day for decades they're getting
fired because they won't comply with
biden's vaccine mandate richard what is
the democrats plan to handle this new
crime wave what are they going to do
about it well look i can't speak to i
mean i'm not a lawmaker but i think what
can be done is because i don't think
it's about defunding the police i don't
think you can mandate policy via hashtag
but i think what we've got to do is one
and bad policing practices like stop and
frisk profiling test of police for uh
excessive over policing and actually
focus on how we do policing better right
because what you have about the
criminals what are you doing hold on a
second hold on a second he's talking
about the criminals i'm not going to be
police i think it's the right i said
nothing like that but that's what you're
you're you went and you did that you
know that excuse me wish list excuse the
things that we've that that has
decimated excuse me she asked you how
you deal with crying
i'm getting i'm getting there right
which what you have is is this when you
talk to communities of color when you
talk to black communities what they tell
you is that 64 of them favor street
patrols 60 60 percent of them favor more
money going towards reform and training
and you also have communities that say
there's a fear and mistrust when it
comes to police and police cannot be
effective if the people who they need to
be effective towards don't trust them so
what you've got to do is have reform in
place so that when you call 9-1-1 you're
going to trust the person on the other
end of the phone and when communities
don't trust who's on the other end of
the phone or who's going to show up when
they call 9-1-1 we have a problem and
until we're willing to acknowledge that
problem exists well we can we'll
continue to have this circular
conversation that gets us nowhere which
is where we are right now i don't think
or no circular current that's what
exactly it's not that's exactly where we
are republicans believe one thing
democrats believe something else in a
circular conversation we refuse to fall
into this prison or two ideas there is
there is so many options on the table
but the moment that you defend the
police at all then you're considered a
racist right i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis